my
citizens we are going to watch the most
popular DC EU movie the end of the DC
extended Universe oh man has arrived
flopping its way into the island it is
Aquaman and the lost kingdom ladies and
gentlemen this came out when there was
several things out that we had to be
very much present for when it came to
editing and stuff so I was like there's
no way I'm watching this in theaters and
I said all right sweet then I could just
react to it with these two gentlemen of
course D John Humphrey and the Andrew
Gordon how are you Andrew Ahoy I'm doing
well I am so excited for the most
anticipated DCU film ever Amen to that
brother uh I was planning on re-watching
the first one last night but due to some
scheduling errors I wasn't able to so I
had to do like editing till really late
at night did you guys rewatch it I took
care that for you don't wor both put it
on while making dinner awesome well I'm
going to rely on you two to remind me of
certain things things but I think I saw
the first one twice in the theater so
should be all right hopefully but you
guys know what to do leave a like on
this video that would be exceptionally
appreciated also subscribe click the
notification Bell to get notified when
we got a reaction up on this channel
that might peque your interest also
thank you to prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights as always the
fulllength reaction watch along that's
where you sync up with your own copy
available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page thank you to all who have
been joining helping us have a awesome
in patreon page over there John and I
cover several things exclusively with
highlights and watch alongs included all
right boys you ready to do this let's do
it my
man man there's so much
fish look at all the fish
yeah
whoa is that death sentence James won
[Applause]
yeah we getting into black manta's
backstory there's this his back I feel
like Aquaman just going to save these
people is what we're getting right but
Black Manta is also on this ship and his
dad's going to die again everybody's
good at something me I talk to fish
that's how I met my
friends hey storm storm from the X I
need a lift he's my
man
o some people think that makes me a joke
you're not a joke aqu man you know why
cuz I'm also good at something else bad
ass and that's breaking heads yeah let's
[Applause]
go all the Pirates whoa I knew idea why
did you have to cut away
there oh
okay
those Chum lickers didn't stand a chance
Chum lickers fun name the Chum
[Applause]
Bucket from
seat sorry pops my bad he's used to this
it's like I'm reading the script for
Boba Fett season 2 leave me alone oh
yeah this is my son you see four years
ago everything changed I met a woman I
fell in love ever her we entered her out
of the
movie wa this little guy's the best who
CG baby
mouth there she is she's in the movie
see this kid he doesn't
[Music]
sleep just how many badass sequences oh
right in the mouth I'm up with crack of
dawn because on top of getting married
and having a kid I finally got a job an
actual job on Hollywood Boulevard I'm
the king of freaking Atlantis I clock in
at 9:00 a.m. but then as it turned out
being King wasn't all it's cracked up to
be just
metics
oh
dude yeah oh my
God who's he narrating to the only thing
that makes all the hard work and
sleepless nights worthwhile is hanging
with my little
man you just pee on it like in the first
movie you just pee on it at least it
wasn't a
turd I to
keep got it that's
cool am I going to take down the legal
cage fighter
too wowe oh awesome but for everything I
get right something else gets screwed
[Music]
up oh quite a visual reaction to that
fir truck there John yeah I had one just
like
a
kid tomor Morris who really has the
widest teeth this is just b-roll of a
day off on
set he's on that Norman Reus AMC show
he's just having a lot more fun being on
land than he is in
Atlantis so he's going to need a little
brother or sister to play with that
ain't happening this is the last one
yeah he's got a
dog sh ious well how lonely it was for
you growing up an only child hey he had
a brother yeah it's true a half brother
don't be too hard on yourself turns out
I have a brother and he's a total back
your relationship with M isn't how it
usually is you be surprised or I'm not
so sure about that cheer siblings bicker
and fight but at the end of the day
their family should be able to count on
them for help should be able to share
Coronas with
them I'll still take the dog over him
any day should have a son and name him
Lobo look at
that oh look out now Aqua Child holy
crap who would have
thought hi baby boy you talking to the
fishies he's riding a new scene for them
my whole life I've wanted to share this
gift with someone you and me son are
different
a I can't wait to introduce you to all
the majestic creatures on our planet
Jason Mo has so much fun yeah I
[Music]
know see the transition bring me a Happy
Meal oh no that's a title
smash can't believe the baby did that a
Title Wave into a title
smash hey man this is moving at a Cheesy
Pace that feels intentional so I'm here
for it I'm having a good time yes I'm
hoping I walk away from this movie going
I got
it this was for
me is that the Black Manta
theme coordinates from Dr Shen nothing
still no sign of at planting remnants
into the
ice oh look at a scar yeah
it's badass funny how his scar is
diagonal but the Mantis scar is straight
down the low down you
know every day I don't fix my power suit
is another day Aquaman gets to live my
power suit where's my super suit check
again we're close this time I can feel
it I'm going to be seeing that
discrepancy with the scar yeah should be
going down diagonal just do it right
down the center of his face
463 Dr Steven Shin recording Randall
Parks David Kane is losing his patience
if I don't turn up the atlantan
technology he's looking for soon they're
probably going to kill you you know what
let's not even go there I'm sure
everything will be fine how are your
magic lessons coming along where is he
going to visit Jack torren yeah he's
going to unearth them please tell me you
found some seismic Ray is going crazy
where's the epicenter standing on oh man
hollower
you found exactly what you were looking
for it's no longer a wild goose
chase oh boy yeah I was going to say
that's usually the the sign to run oh
no a trench is opening up oh what a fun
shot oh oh oh
damn ooo
actually I'm sure this was a Paar down
cut down movie but in terms of Direction
I see more of James Juan's actual camera
style influence more than what I recall
feeling for the first one already well
we're in more tangible situations yeah
so it's like less in the
computer
I think it was a piece of ice sheet
breaking
off it was the title
card no there's an effect effect with
the sound
effects oh there's that
aect
[Music]
no
sweet oo wa wait a minute oh oh see like
it create an actual symbol or a shape I
think I
my got put some ice on
it
[Music]
oh
wa anime tentacle
[Music]
creature
who found the upside
down oh oh my
God no
gloves that's James Juan horrror right
there who Mr cthulu and all these wide
angle lenses okay we're like 15 minutes
in I'm still having
fun let's do a fun checkin every five
fun
checkin the hell happened to you oh
there's something back there is it my
trench spin-off but on said James mom
was like referencing the thing the whole
time yeah I was thinking about that the
thing meet stranger
things whoa questionable CGI there's
CGI how was this place even possible
this was all probably solid ice until we
started heating the planet it's all our
faults well thank God for global warming
in my right here here hell no I am anti
Black Manta now I mean
no the tracks Le down there sud up the
tracks lead down there which means the
monster down there we're going to
retrieve
Excalibur neat it's going to be like
that James Cameron water cave movie I
don't believe this it's a structure of
some kind and there's more bued in the
very good
observation
everyone out and search yes sir we
stumbled upon something big here duck
this is heavy this has to be a few
thousand years old astounding it's going
to be great on my YouTube channel so
he's just trying to find Tech to make
his black mantis suit more oh my God
he's having so much more fun here that's
so freaky I wonder how many of those
trench spin-off ideas got folded into
this uh
oh oh that's creepy oh nice
nice oh what was the plan here
exactly oh come on man kick his ass
kanen
yeah oo just tell the monster you want
revenge on Aquaman he'll understand
stand just ask to borrow some of his
power nicely I don't know maybe on TV it
looks better but so far the effects look
really great other than the times when
they
don't but some of them most of the time
they look all
right oh oh there's more of an assured
hand I feel with the camera work that
tried a war
to the
wise is it the black
Trident
W
yeah let's go
fun oh yes yes free me from my PR I will
grant you the strength to kill the man
who murdered your father no he's using
you kind of you need to live so you can
kill that son of a [__] that was his
back story from what he stole from you
oh now it's premonition terrain his home
will burn his kingdom
will very Avengers Age of Ultron wow his
entire life set a
flame D DAV
DAV David I I'll cut you I'll cut you
squid crap
[Music]
battle I'm just going to say it if if
Sam ry's name was slapped onto this I
think people would be a lot more
forgiving I think it' be the exact same
shot
movie like feel like a Sam Ry movie they
let him do his thing you guys see
that oh no
oh God what are you doing
here be careful on the bed the council
has called for an emergency Gathering
there's been another plague outbreak son
of a [__] hey that was a good line
delivery all right was it I thought it
was the worst line delivery in the
entire movie John I have listened to
every line delivery in history of Cinema
the surface has been poisoning our
atmosphere for over a century we fixed
that last time you can't expect them to
care about what happens to us if they
don't even know we exist if you want to
be a part of the conversation we have to
take our seat at the table H like
wakanda the high table it's time for
Atlantis to reveal itself to the surface
let's call Batman and get on this maybe
some other
time and I know this is against our
Traditions but the world is shrinking
and the old ways aren't going to protect
us anymore can't be isolationists I like
how his hair is moving but does not look
like he's
underwater know have you already
forgotten that this plague killed k your
own beloved mentle oh okay there's our
William defo did they just kill off
Willam defo I pretty sure they just said
that maybe he'll show up to surprise us
if we ever decide to make ourselves
known to the surface dwellers it will be
to eradicate them not to coexist but I
bought that coexist bumper sticker so he
needs to go to the surface and he's
dealing with Black Manta again okay a
lot of stuff from the first movie
but it's kind of rare for a like these
com movies to feel like a direct sequel
to the last one sure you know sure sure
no really just like let's got brand new
this brand everything's brand new whole
new phase New Era new everything there
and I have the whole Kingdom helping us
that little baby boy still kicking our
asses and you taking care of me raising
me on your own where the hell is Nicole
Kidman she's filming an AMC commercial
ah you're the real superhero we are I am
Bubba
Fett vocal told me to bring the land and
the Sea together problem is half of
Atlantis still wants to destroy the
surface it won't listen I can't bring
[__] together voo believed in you here
here I I
know I'm missing we do too the audience
what a crck of [__] it's like the worst
sequel thing you can do yeah it is
annoying I just keept going you
celebrate the wins you mourn the losses
and you wake up the next day and you do
it again sometimes not giving up is the
most heroic thing you can do these zooms
have me expecting a jump
scare oh speaking aori that's my native
native tongue oh dude I wish speak it so
I could know what they said too they
they said
uh I am Bubba he called him my man and
then Arthur said that's
badass somewhere in the Atlantic
what a cool set yeah is it just because
my expectations were so low that I am
enjoying I feel like I've enjoyed this
more than the first one sure sure it's
just it just seems like it's really
embraced The Voice the fun voice so far
I'm definitely enjoying it more than the
first one so far he's got a suit he's
got cool Wolverine suit humans were not
made to live at these depths you just
remember who built this ship more
worried about how long ago they built it
they literally look like the X-Men in X3
like I like the Retro bovie SciFi look
that they they have with this right
[Music]
now this feels like alien with a
combination of fantasy you know feel
like I'm watching like a really big
budget Power Rangers well that's how I
felt with the first one oh no he's got
the nose blood Expedition log day 613
jeez Kane is off on our most dangerous
Mission yet a three-man octobot
infiltration team
[Music]
wa these ancient machines we found still
function after all these years but they
require very specialized fuel to keep
them running Kane calls it orac Calcom
uh-oh I'll remember that it's that
malevolent Spirit suddenly he knows
secrets that he couldn't possibly know
including the only way to obtain this
oric alcome is to steal it from highly
protected storage vaults wow he also
informed me there wasn't enough time to
show this all happening so I had to
record this monologue to get it out of
the way quick say the time frame on this
is a bit confusing said 5 months later
what was the 6 but this is the 613th day
that they've been on a
journey okay you have 15 minutes to get
in and out no margin for error you can't
go through the In-N-Out driveway in 15
minutes no depends what time and night
hardly ever
yes this should take you
through oo buddy those are pretty cool
ships yeah I like the designs of them
for sure I got like the swirling that
left to right like a fan octopus
legs
wowe open sesame
nice lens flares man stay vigilant we
have no idea what kind of security
measures they have down there they got a
guard just hanging
out he talks like the octopus from
Madagascar yeah this is like a
swashbuckling video game
yeah it's a fetch Quest
I'm thought that was Henry Cav we got no
reason to defend this this is the last
one does us no favor you know burn it
all down if we if we must but also this
kind of fun this is really fun loading
barge now
wowe oh no we're trapped it's a trap
change of plans I need an extraction now
oh h to battle station
oh two arms there's so much diversity in
this
movie woke
Atlantis I found it it exists I'm in
traffic you are illegally here you are
out of Transit Zone doctor power up the
Sonic battery illegal border crossing
will be met with deadly force no oh no
commencing
charge it's pretty cool how much bigger
of a role they gave him they really
follow through with that hydro cannon at
front gate locking in on target charger
set to maximum
power Intruder in sight take them out oh
no oh what are you waiting for fire oh
no don't fire on your discovery
oh no oh they got some real weapons
whoa like a sonar gun oh
D oh [__] going ham so imposing the
stakes have been raised sir atlantan
hostiles are
approaching split up oh now it feels
real yeah The
Zo vault is that Nicole Kidman we just
saw there we go hey
what heartbreak feels good on a shark
like
this I like the armor the sharks have
it's pretty
cool watch out for the
civilians oh my goodness
great oh no they're they're date they're
me cute
woo
w
awesome come on
Atlanta come
on how cool I'm watching an anime man
this is so
[Music]
Funt it's a good good looking out
shark
merge onto the freeway maximum speed of
600 knots speed let's go Amber let's go
Queen oh excellent look how freaking
cool this is come on like a turtle no no
little dude it's like in Star Trek when
they're in warp
speed
whoa oh that is so cool wow gave a
pretty badass moment got me
[Music]
oh is this the moment she punches it yes
ooh oh
[__] wa nice
implosion oh
damn
oh ooh
ruthless not yet I'm going to kill me a
dead mermaid oh what that suit looks so
much better than the first movie oh no
oh
no my bad
man get away from my wife keep my wife's
name out your
mouth oh wow atlantian Army is headed
this way if we don't leave now we're
dead got to get my revenge oh my
god oh crap save those
[Music]
people I get revenge first who cares
about these people that's
fair excellent tracking shot
yeah
[Music]
a
ah
J nice Toby would be proud yes I think
this feels more tangible and lived in
wa oh wowe the
Sonic come on
[__]
A what wow nice it's like being an
Aquaman's perspective so sudden damn and
the soundtrack is much better so far too
dude that was a great action scene yeah
that was a genuinely great action scene
H with it the throne is the heart of at
too often now it stands empty while our
King spends half his time on l oh
they're questioning him tragedy is
merely a taste of the Havoc that will be
rought I'm okay put her in a back to
tank cannot protect his own family a how
is he supposed to protect us dude hats
off to rert Cs and Williams I'm really
enjoying the score so far those Gregson
Williams mans do we know what was Thorn
Aqua beards he escaped with a large
stockpile of orul am I supposed to know
what that is power source that was used
in ancient times it emits tremendous
amounts of greenhouse gases that are
highly destructive to our planet in fact
we almost destroyed the oceans ourselves
before we realized what we were doing
they almost made the same mistakes as
the humans can't be disposed of safely
so the remaining stockpile has been
buried in 12 storage vaults deep
underground no we should one the other
places that are throwing this stuff it's
already been there it's all gone emptied
them all out this spike in global
temperatures that's causing disasters on
the surface making the seadweller sick
happened 5 months ago he's using the
storm or calom to heat the planet he
made the title card he must be stopped
or a global climate meltdown is imminent
we need to find I feel like this is
topical what do you
mean I think I know someone that might
build to help us you're not going to
like it your brother oh yeah he's the
only one who might know how to find him
in time the fisherman will never allow
you to speak to him he killed her King
yeah I wasn't exactly going to ask for
permission my dad told me to talk to him
he's like I saw Thor the Dark World I
can work with my brother I'm going to
break him out myself Arthur Caron is
looking for a
reason waa this looks weird what's going
on here out there where I belong where
I'm actually good at what I do tired of
nothing ever getting done this looking
so strange What's Happening Now else a
it's a lot of stuff it's the CG hair
it's the lighting the CG face elements
don't do closeup let me not get caught
all right this is straight up toward the
Dark
World o it's got a very different energy
I just mean the plan secret one of aind
underground facility they're assuming no
sea dweller would ever dare cross the
desert nice special outfit for you is
that boys exra medum chat Force change
color and camouflage you for up to a
minute making you undetectable who it's
the most sens they'll never see you
coming that's pretty cool at least for
the minute that you can use it are too
risky I'll be sending a yeah they they
really made them edit this down yep I'm
thinking they making it work though
that's an octopus T that's a drummer my
friend too for sure too too Chico
engineered intelligence for infiltration
and Espionage he also plays a variety of
musical instruments Topo he does like in
the first movie where he played drums
toppo gets an expanded role well he was
the most popular character in The First
movie your hect starting to smell like
warm CH
butter man there's a lot of uh lot of
liquid splatting on Aquaman jokes is ink
piss you just pee on it like the first
movie Death woring Aesthetics surv and
dry by turning to blood they're like
evil groots cool they're limiting his
water supply just enough to keep him
alive sure and if you do see arm you
tell him that I love him yes Queen fr I
mean Atlanta once you broken arm out
you're not going to be able to turn your
back on him you need him but you can
never trust him so kill
him oh damn oh oh no tase me
bro Patrick Wilson shirtless Patrick
Wilson's always shirtless
yes look at him
go
oh my God such a cool design on these
dudes yeah it actual practical makeup
oh we're in like Army of Darkness right
now
[Music]
oh wow they really made it seem like
this was going to be a real challenge
yes but they did it in 3
minutes what the hell are you you doing
here I'm going to break you out if you
lost your mind you must be very
desperate you're the one who put me here
why you bringing up
[__] I got to stop David Kan from
destroying the world and you're the only
one that can help me so you do the math
do they CGI it must a CGI down his body
right uh it looks like it Cast Away crab
Wilson let's roll crab
[Music]
Wilson oh so what he like gets dipped in
water and he'll get his muscles back or
something I would imagine so yeah this
changes nothing yeah wouldn't have it
any other way little brother just give
us 20 minutes of screen time then we'll
Bond call me half brother come on too
you stupid squid wake up and open the
door you Ain so mad at the squid for the
seod trust me it wasn't my idea hey put
some respect on toppo's name he's doing
[__] none of you could do he's squeezing
into tight
spaces come on all
right oh my
God creatures are so icky and
cool look they they didn't get Willam to
Thro but they did get William to Thro
from last temptation of Jesus
Christ you know how to ride one of these
are you kidding I don't even know what
the hell it
is Ride The Finger
monster who yeah
yeah there's a lot of sing looking
creatures in this
[Music]
one reminds me of Batman's wallall
crawler in Zack Snider's Justice League
there you go it's a tribute to the SN
cut oh yeah who oh damn they burrow what
a specific kind of creature was pretty
inventive to
me get out of here stay out I just
wanted you off my
back I love how it was like 10 minutes
ago they introduced breaking him out and
then made his whole like it's going to
be this this this this and it's
extremely simple well he's got the
Predator suit so I mean you know oh
no save him orm
take back our
prize water oh yeah in the just get him
in the water all you need is a little
bit he's like Percy
Jackson yeah this is when you get off
and you go on foot when he's this close
to the water is when you get off and go
off yeah all we need is a tide boy all
we need is a
tide let's go oh my God he's being
baptized he's being
rehydrated hydrate level four
please is it
ready
oh yeah wow nice detail with I need to
stop working out I just need to go into
[Music]
water let's go let's
go
oh
looks like Alexander scars guard now
yeah Tarzan over here badass
way
wowe whoa what the hell yeah you can't
save that weird looking CGI with a frame
rate change
man oh nice nice dude hell yeah
sidekick
[Laughter]
literally oh King [__] to do back in
Atlanta
go come this run doing like a low-key
Naruto
run yeah why isn't he moving his arms
what's up with his
arms the real King has returned yeah but
he has a bunch of fanatic loyalists down
here give every your try that
or should be reinstated you know if the
pressures of leadership are too
stressful perhaps you should leave and
let someone who knows what they're doing
be king I agree let Tapo be the king
just help me find this [__] my
contact will at least know where to look
he looks so uncomfortable I know look
like they have to like force themselves
to squeeze into I knew was ruthless but
he wasn't insane J this guy just put a
gun to the world's head and pulled the
trigger without even making any demands
he's drunk with power I don't know about
this whole like possessed thingy I
thought his motivation was enough yeah
but he's got to be powerful enough yeah
but her layer of some type of weird
possession thing I agree with you but he
got he got his ass kicked so easily in
the first movie so they had to give him
have him power up I'm just talking about
The Possession part I'm just talking
power okay the power part I get
Andrew I think his look is cool with the
green eyes but like this whole he's
insane because of the
[Music]
thingy this is giving me almost like a
Krypton feel from Man of
Steel Snider tributes Snider
[Applause]
tribute and green like Kryptonite and
and this could destroy our world like a
Kryptonite with Superman I didn't think
we'd ever actually have to use it on
anyone wants to go back to Atlantis we
are this close to unlocking the greatest
power in human history are you you
really telling me you want to walk away
now yeah if it's going to destroy the
world if I said yes would you like me
wait a
minute sure you want to see how long you
last in that jungle was that always the
angle of the scar be my guest okay they
would have messed that up you would you
would hope but no yeah it was coming
from that cheek up to that side of his
forehead at least yeah I'll Stick Around
stick around they scavenged ships from
around the world to build this place
cool it is the one place in the world
where the scum of the land and sea
mingle scum of the land and see come on
it is where people come to disappear an
impressive [__]
hole how have I never heard of this
place before it's not meant to be common
knowledge it's a pirate Haven [__]
lantis listen I don't know if you know
this about me but I'm not too popular of
pirates I dress like Johnny Deber
earlier and it did not go well and
there's a lot of R here
too oh I'm well
wereare you can't trust him relax it was
the only way to get us both
in
Hammerheads whoa It's Blade Runner
underwater different dude on the drums
though let my man toppo get in there
they're all different creatures John
it's like the Contin only too could play
the
drums yeah they've got way more sci-fi
this time that's
Kingfish he Brokers deals with pirates
mercenaries slavers you name it Street
Sharks helping out he's are best shot at
finding Manta and he's not going to tell
us anything if you go in there flexing
your muscles at him do the peck dance
you think you I'm strong I didn't
realize you've been released from prison
Martin Short Jaba I literally just said
that in my head we need to find David
Kane bad news David Kane is no longer on
the market oh he's slowely running as an
independent operator and a Smooth
Operator where does he hold up now in
exchange I offer a favor my brother a
sexual favor from the king of Atlantis
you seriously expect me to play footy
with someone with that kind of blood on
their hands I don't hurt
him I've run rings around you logically
if the information checks out good
promise you that I won't immediately
come back here and tear this place part
oh with that kind of a deal
traditionally the kings of Atlantis have
turned a blind eye to the sunken Citadel
now we have to Blind it for you
oh offer him a seat at the
table man I like the look of a lot of
this but it's not exactly the most
gripping stuff
Muses no no
no take it easy on the Street
Sharks
[Music]
yeah
head
wowe what
chaos
wow
oh damn oh no is it it going to explode
I don't know where he is but there have
been rumors a a dormant volcano in the
South Pacific called Devil's deep oh
badass name Travelers say there's a
jungle there now navigation gets
scrambled as soon as you start to get
close and if you get too close you don't
come back oh and believe me I am I'd say
that SP K is hiding
out whoa or
whoa that's kind of what I kind of
summarizes this whole movie yeah we got
what we needed next scene let's get out
of here we got we got more PL to get
on deep sea Rihanna uh yeah we are St
after once we got to or breakout point I
started feeling like okay the trim down
stuff is I think starting to actually
affect my experience with this movie yep
starting to feel a bit like a highlight
reel if anything it's even easier now we
couldn't have planned it any better than
American Werewolf in London who are you
talking to mirror mirror on the wall who
is the blackest Manta of
all somewhere it is at a point where I'm
like okay I need the noise to slow down
a time a little bit just a t starting to
become a little
loud
woo I've seen this Pixar short but when
the action kicks in it is really like I
think the I think the action is really
great oh yeah you know would be amazing
right now reinforcements great big
greasy cheeseburger and a pine of
Guinness now this feels like Predator
the words that surface dwellers give
their food sound disgusting enjoying
half the world what do you think about
that you're lost
dude love how are the intense situations
become the goofier Arthur because yeah
man that's how he copes what is it oh my
God no one no one oh he's totally
pranking him oh yeah shrimp of the
land oh my God that looks like a real
roach
too that's funny it's not now but that's
funny got
protein oh my god dude and I mean a
coconut like a good coconut not a rotten
coconut would be like you know Mother
Nature you know that's not even man's
food it's not surface dweller
food pandor don't say stuff like that
when I'm already thinking half the time
what happens if James what would happen
if James came C directed this you know
he did an Entourage guys you got to get
this out of your head about James
Cameron and all
that oh are you seeing
this it's not normal oh they're like on
Skull
Island it's what happens when you put
that green crap in there or the Predator
bleed all over it 20 a
months you just ate that roach wow that
is a big rat is sad oh no pizza rat rest
in peace wow we are on Skull
Island great location you guys ate the
Cockroach I am wondering low key like I
bet nothing will happen but at the same
time run like that I don't know I'm used
to run it's like I
saw used to swimming
[Laughter]
like holy sh [__]
yeah that's
awesome thank you giant plant okay
that's CGI this is very much like a
video game this
[Music]
movie whoa what a wild cacophony of
plant
life oh [__] wow I like it more than the
latest Indiana Jones movie that was the
best one what are you talking about
who's that what's that say writing this
ancient atlantan through King builds
Bridges hey look at
that
ow oh my God this really is a video
game it
worked oh it did work building a bridge
unless it breaks in
half luckily it didn't break half hey I
forgot to tell you she loves
you you told me this now I'm just tired
of waiting for the right moment I'm just
tired of waiting for them to let us let
this movie breathe normally so I'm just
going to tell you
now
wowe oh yeah these things have Hops and
wings oh
wow
don't all those bugs have wings I think
they were grasshopper I don't know Jason
mimo just relies so much on having fun
that at times I don't even care because
sometimes they'll do like they'll cut to
the next line of his at a different shot
and it just doesn't seem like it's
transitioning smooth from the previous
shot like screw it he's having fun yeah
you can't deny his Charisma energy even
though it feels like they shot this at a
different time of day or a different day
in total what's contagious too is energy
like comes on to us as
well oh pick it up unlock your inner
power
uh don't put them together is it going
to be some Rush finale villain or a post
credit scene this is the dceu we could
get another black atom
[Music]
dude
yes same guy's going to be like I've
been waiting for you
wowe the dead armies armies of dun
Harrow she touching my stuff okay doc
you want to know my plan so bad yeah I
kind of forget you're in this movie I'm
going to kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds dear I thought we
already knew that I'm going to murder
his family and burn his kingdom to Ash I
will avenge my father m oh boy I have to
make a deal with the devil to do it sure
David you can't trust the Trident four
out of five dentists agree I never draw
this blade unless it's going to taste
blood oh pray I never show it to you
again oh you just broke the rule of the
blade oh it had to taste blood Fair fa
you got him on the loophole he's so much
more intimidating in this film obviously
he's got way more screen time but still
I guess I still think he could be a lot
better I feel like with his actual
character motivation he could be more
intimida but I like that he's here he's
more effective yeah than the last one
for sure I just thought he was so cheesy
in the last one yeah look Loki I'm not
asking for your advice Loki he called
him lowy that's what I said earlier Thor
the Dark World go back to askat for all
I making all they Embrace what they were
doing I think this one is more
self-aware by a lot that's what I'm
saying they're embracing what they're
doing you're the one who swam through
the front gate and challenged my claim
for the throne only because you're
trying to destroy the surface world if
you weren't such an [__] you'd still
be king wait wait you took my throne and
you don't even want it are you kidding
me I hate this job he could be the King
again from the day my father found out
you existed he prepared me for the
moment that you would come and challenge
me for the throne oh that's really sad
especially when you think how easily I
kicked your ass with basically no prep
time once
while I didn't even stretch that day but
was it really you or the Trident just
saying
no look at this look at there's such a
retro vibe to it yeah it's a retro it's
like amalgamation of like retro sci-fi B
movies swashbuckling video games it's
like Uncharted if if it was Aquaman or
something I don't know unch
Aquaman there's something like a real
fun sets and the depths look real you it
does feel like you're watching The
Hobbit or something in terms of like how
the ruction values are coming together
and this is a nice one cool tracking
shot
yeah do one of those glass things
yeah
nice
woo
boom don't want to be your monkey wrench
let me kill him what was the problem
with shooting he you know you probably
murdered that guy sibling rivalry that
guy's more than likely dead this whole
place must be heat shielded to protect
it from the surfaces thermal satellites
question is how do we stop I take out
this reactor we would have to Crater the
entire Island get away from there oh no
come on you agree with them you like
Atlantis this Blaster may be ancient but
it was built for killing atlantans real
intimidating don't try to mean mugget
man okay I am so sorry I did not mean
I'm a scientist David Kane said he could
help me but now he won't let me leave
you expect us to believe you have
nothing to do with this I know I've done
things I'm not proud of um but he would
have killed me if I
hadn't knock him out no no no then I'll
knock him out no oh but I want to knock
someone out you can come with us thank
you he's going to die right now it's a
direct link to some ancient evil it
gives Cain great powers and in with
great
responsibility
no and he's got no resp he takes no
responsibility ouch cheese I do find it
funny how there hasn't been much like I
hate when that happens making F of so
many seen and the last one just explode
to a next scene he's barely done like
actual Aquaman
action
[Music]
whoa boom Boomerang nice Captain
Boomerang Suicide
Squad
yeah Dam
geometry he is just murdering humans
left and right it's okay it's not
Batman yeah anybody else can do it oh
Dam that's
spooky he can't hear it
yep it's way too low reminded me when
the alien came out the xenomorph and
Aliens out of the water for n you got
nothing but references Andrew that's on
me woo
ouchies damn that
[Applause]
shot damn Foot Right the camera that's
great camera work man that's some great
ass camera work now he knows how to sell
it James Juan knows how to bring the
movie m magic
together save him
[Music]
Arthur that's my brother yeah you do
that to
family oh ouch
cheese ooh where the hell is black
man they're not making a lot of noise or
anything no no no no no not the or Calum
you want to blow us up this stuff blows
up yes this stuff blows up of course it
blows up let's see
some yes D look how humongous those
chains are they're like comically big
Anchors
Away woo
yeah there like get a slime sound effect
just
there it's just funny
like oh nice you're the AT-AT walker in
this experiment I I like that sequence a
lot because they're they have to utilize
their super strength but kind of like
Jackie Chan ask use items around them
that are just so massive that only a
superhuman could physically move it
around yeah there he is David or my
guard I never expected to see you two
fighting side by side nor did we just
for
you damn
it that posture they have't in I was
going to kill you last but thanks for
dropping by action scene
two oh he should have dropped something
when you said thanks for dropping
by oh oh damn nice come at me the killer
of King come at me
bro
[Music]
woo ah just love stacking up against
these massive industrial
items dang don't touch
it
ah oh
no oh no The
Taste the taste that was at land we just
saw
yeah
wowe oh God get him in the water he's
got mirrored get him in the water that
was a cool shot of
[Music]
atan
whoa
starfish take that Island down nous
let's go
King oh sweet you show that mean Island
whose
boss oh
yeah war
[Music]
war yeah let's
go wow that's I I do think they such a
great job on the scale when you see like
the human characters against everything
else like I like that they let the
humans look tiny in comparison yeah it's
really colorful too yeah well I mean a
lot of these movies can be very dra and
gray
[Music]
[Applause]
like oh the Sonic Cannon I'm going to go
kill your father and baby
help him
arm water
[Music]
physics Ora yes
Queen chills everywhere she's in the
movie now wrap your legs around
him I'm sorry to drag you all under this
but the fisherman can't think that
Atlant was involved now this looks like
Power
Rangers Kingdom has not forgotten its
debt to you you may count on us always
so count as one what you guys always
make the comments at the same time it's
like in a in a race to com comment YouTu
what is what who was that I know he
can't be trusted and he cut off my claw
that sounds like pet Reese Davies John
Reese
Davies
[Laughter]
I saw the lost kingdom you remember he
in Indiana Jones how do you know what
you saw was the lost kingdom oh they
said the name of the movie It's called
necris
oh and I didn't just see it I knew it
NEC during King ATL's time there were
seven United Kingdoms of Atlantis and
the black city was a curse upon them all
uh-oh everyone looks so much more
saturated on that land yeah
she knows like everyone's color is just
so much for
striking by exploiting oracal necris
rapidly became a superpower unlike any
other but it came at a terrible price
poisoning the land wowe ATL's own
brother cordex
cordex to stop using it before the world
was irrevocably damaged it's that guy
it's euron gr Droid thinking his own
brother was trying to steal his power
they definitely didn't cut out any of
his scenes nope instrument of
evil the black
Trident One Trident to rule them all he
transformed his people and himself into
monsters he made the Orcs to fight
Atlantis so the two brothers went to war
God oh my God they can't have history
repeat itself they have to change
this
o and imprisoned him at all of necris
with a spell cast with his own blood ah
is
s to ensure that cord's dark power would
never be
found y'all got to start destroying this
[__] outright and not just burying it
evil was supposed to remain Frozen for
eternity Let It Go but David Kane has
found it and it's slowly possessing him
oh Alan used blood magic to steal cordex
in his prison only Allan himself could
release him Manta doesn't need atlet
himself man needs atan blood duh the key
to cord's prison is the Royal bloodline
itself what does that mean he needs
blood from either you me or Arthur
that's what it means guys oh my God I
just put it together just now when he
said that we're The End Of The Bloodline
oh no no we're not the
baby do it movie now it's turned into
Ghostbusters 2 precedented weather
events across the globe and
meteorologists are at a loss to explain
this rapid there's so many dead animals
in this movie
one of's going to
die oh no if they kill the baby big
respect bold movie bold move oh nice
that was sick
shot
[Music]
no Jesus that's C you dead
baby papa and and the baby I'm sorry son
where what do you
care
J
no oh yeah
baby oh no I love this
movie oh my God that was so funny I
think them telling them to parir it down
sometimes is is the best thing they
could have
done cuz then you get past all other
[__] it's like they probably want to
dramatically hit so hard where you're
like I can't take this serious aam's
razor man sometimes the simplest answer
is the best did you see that one two
three no no
no so funny I'll never forget that meant
to be taken seriously but
laughable move over Vader's
no oh is broadcasting on an old
Atlantean sonar frequency it's Morse
code bring a little one back yes don't
have this conversation with your wife I
like that they got with your mom you
really do forget that that is also mea's
baby I like that they got she ran out
screaming I was like why is she so upset
oh that's
right promise me you will protect each
other promise me more or I'm going to do
my
[Music]
best family a the aqua fam like that
they brought Atlanta's theme back from
the first film oh a reference to the
actual thing we're
watching I was going to say that's a
reference to my family cuz you know I
have a mom and a brother right I would
have made sense I ruined
[Laughter]
it our only chance is to hit him with
total overwhelming force from every
direction not with Junior and the
crossfire something about DOL
lundon it's got like a little bit of a
dude thing going on this
movie what if we disrupt those Echoes
with another sound wave on the same
frequency but just it's much much louder
the loudness Wars that's going to be the
easy part oh we are true
disruptors Arthur you got so dumb after
all I've been spending my time my Muscle
Beach when I'm not the
throne give me some sunad oil man
I am the weapon I don't need it he's not
just capable of grabbing
it oh dude and then Dwayne Johnson's
going to throw the missile at it in a
minute mean a stronger reference
probably would have been galado do
showing up at the top like at the end of
that's fair yeah because she's in both
franchises you know so Dwayne Johnson
that's right the power hierarchy did
change didn't
it all we did was fast forward things a
few years yeah this was already going to
happen power up the Sonic can drop the
beat is he going to see the air of his
ways I hope not love how they made this
one notee villain from Aquaman 1 even
more one not I know just with much more
screen time how do we take a character
that would have been fine enough on its
own and play into one of the worst
tropes of our own
franchise
oo
[Applause]
yeah it's the title
sequences yeah the
premonition oh my God you could roll an
emck this oh yeah the Dodge it all the
day after
[Music]
tomorrow oh here we
go fishes
[Music]
assemble oh no the whales are
pissed whoa can ship take them all out
they're just animals aren't they just
regular
animals there's a whole realm of power
that sea creatures have that we are just
unaware of taste of your own
medicine
wow
wowe did the the fish they did that they
just combine the power of all of their
sonar high pitch frequencies and
overwhelm the system I guess is that
what happened that's what I took from
that I took what he took thank you for
that explanation John any old time okay
sorry guys this movie is too smart for
me that's really why they need to reboot
the DCU just flying over everyone's
heads
[Music]
damn that is Icky looking it's like a
skull peering down Into the Depths Back
to Where it All
Began is immense it could be anywhere
the throat of necris is in the heart of
the city I sense Something In The Water
everyone light it
up light it
up constellations you say that cardx
turned his people people into an army of
monsters yes I did uh imminent action
sequence
ahead oh
no where is
Will
woo damn no music to compliment it's
crazy yes Queen this would be a good
time to call in all those an
mammals ooh nice go now and save the
prince thank you your in whoa whoa whoa
thank you Mr Crabs CGI was really off
[Music]
yeah I don't know what I'm looking at I
mean there are a lot of invertebrates
under the sea I don't even know John ree
Davies is supposed to be he's Mr
Krabs release the armies of dun Haro
sometimes the the speed on the CGI of
the humans is so weird
yeah Oh
e use your axe yeah
man oh no not show him you're a better
person now not now
dude no his expression
he like
really
hey
a fine I have no other
tentacles just the one I
needed I mean orm's not a bad guy oh
sign of respect oh damn I mean did good
barnica boy was orm really ever a bad
guy you know he just had some bad
uh bad some bad policies you where he
was coming from man they're why wouldn't
you what we live in
America was like screw these people
going to
war step our foot in other people's Wars
and I was like you know this makes
sense oh my dude you did it
ah well he's clearly going to be be the
king at the end of this yeah
yeah wa damn the double tap let's
go she she's just like a little Easter
egg
character oh let's go Uncle Shin damn
baby must be
freezing
oo to grow spine ouch he's not
wrong
[Music]
oh the knife the blood knife of
blood nautical baby
monitor
bam that was a good line to
learn War Blood come get it yeah man
let's do it Go Mermaid Man
go
woo when will the beat
drop King Shin
aquan no one calls him Aquaman I know he
only been called it like twice including
that one damn dude that was a great shot
yeah tell man look at this [__] this is
way cooler let's go Aquaman Warehouse
fight Trident versus
Trident this is a badass shot yeah
dude
woo damn it's like an anime it really
is
oo orm save him you wear my brother's
arm and wield his stdent but you're only
half the man he was I am 10 times the
King Mufasa
was
let's
go every time I say that Mara saves him
Mera just keeps showing up in a nick of
time yeah she's the MVP of the movie
she's in the
movie that's our baby yes it is his
stand over it for a
second
go oh
[__] whoa yeah Snider shot
going to look at it oh yeah Barnacle
Boy run fight
it free me from my prison all my power
will be yours no don't listen as
Sauron this
Sor
oh oh green eyes are gone from him ah
damn it damn it barnacle Bo kill him and
you will be Ocean Master
again
no fall into a side
splits either you kill your brother or
you die it's just a dead ey don't listen
to
it
a the blood the blood the mouth blood
destroy the Trident the Bin's blood is
Magic magic is
broken Magic it again I'm done find your
puppet's cax I'm coming for
you who you doing watching this don't
let him take it hasn't he taken it up
already that's from the first movie it's
time for me to reclaim my destiny you
can have it you were foolish to think he
could ever change you are the one true
king it l deserves it's one true king
just hopping around between both yeah
he's literally playing both sides and
the one true king don't worry you're
going to be the King by the end of the
movie calm down you both need to put it
down you know there was a time when I
wanted to meet you more than anything
let you know that you weren't alone that
we were in it together that's from the
first movie protect each other this from
this movie come full circle this
development is just so compelling no
matter what you are not alone or this
together oh he got the teardrop Aqua
tier Let it
go Let it go Let it go can't hold it
back
anymore I live
again I waited come for centuries in the
dark for this moment after 10,000 years
I'm
free who [__]
why would that work my
[__]
wow oh
go yeah yeah there we go there we go
destroy it yeah just like in The Suicide
Squad
ooo it's like I live again for 30
seconds damn best DC EU villain
ever black man is the second
one let him
die look let him have an unceremonious
death he didn't save his father is he
going to save
him bring It full circle art come out oh
he's going to save him I just hope a
rock hits him don't beg the ocean for
forgiveness are you going to take his
hand though
just fall just fall
psych it's so generic what a tragic
death oh no they even they even had them
trim that down we need the mid credit
scene showing how he
survived there you go perfect for 10 10
out of 10 you're going to the Olympics
couples
diving Dr sh can you swim yeah
it's okay he can survive sub subzero
temperatures come on
baby what the
[Music]
[__] everyone gets a
ride that Dr Shin survived this
woo look at those water Sims but what
happened to Mr
Krabs yeah what happened to Mr
Krabs so Dr Shin just like got here all
dry and yep he's good he just got thrown
up by that squid machine and he's fine
his regular survive in Antarctica just a
regular human thank
you dude take him to Atlantis
astounding
astounding hey that still only comes us
one my carw got cut off your debt is
paid not everybody's going to see it
that way though might as is why be king
it's too bad you went and had yourself
killed back there love this cliche all
this ice it'd be impossible to find the
body I love this cliche orm spin-off
let's go keep him in the DC gun verse
may need to call you up for some advice
you know with the whole running a
kingdom thing and then he spins off into
his own 18am franchise interesting
really thought he was going to end up
being
King
brother the emotional Arc is complete
now
kiss
yeah the forearm shake you son of a
[__] the shake of Kings you do the
right thing when doing the wrong thing
is much easier and you're willing to ask
for help even from your worst enemy you
really took Dumbledore's
[Laughter]
advice if you lead Atlantis will follow
now do a barrel roll after all true king
builds Bridges right that knock down a
statue thought that was just a metaphor
your metaphor might have just saved the
world's ass I'm going to get a
burger oh my God is it
over we got Dr Shin where's Dr Shin
entire civilization hidden for thousands
of years about to be revealed where's
the UN none of this is going to
[Music]
matter oh my God the king of Atlantis
has reached out to the United Nations
and will be it's literally it really is
that ending the result of weeks of
secret negot ation with the United
Nations we now go live would people be
wowed by it we got a Superman
already but not from under the
sea I mean it's different it's like
you've had a hidden civilization for so
long I come here today as a
representative of Two Worlds the land
and the Sea and I stand here as proof
change is coming to both and I'm calling
for Global Unity absolutely Atlanta
stands ready to help contribute its
science and technology that b did it
seem strange unfamiliar cheeseburger the
you got the burger you called it joh bur
oh I'm the king of Atlantis I am Iron
Man I am
Aquaman you got to do that you got do
the Iron Man thing literally just mic
dropped literally mik dropped the end of
the
movie
Bravo Never Comes
did the story I didn't know that how
many people have set like movies to this
song I want a list of all the movies
that use this song as like a badass
character
Theme all right everyone guess them mid
credits or post credits in go oh they
both get a burger no wait that he gets a
divorce from Queen
Mera
uh a teas are for Boba Fett no it's
Black Manta surviving in all the green
stuff that's right third billing
baby b to be or to be wild Martin Short
called that [__] I called that [__] yeah
I had a I thought that was him when I
was listening to that voice John looked
it up on
IMDb I looked the whole movie and plot
lineup and all the cast and the guy from
from Game of Thrones he spoke one line
and you were like it's smart and short
yeah I know his voice
anywhere and then the more he kept
talking I started to have doubts but it
all paid off in the
end
nah Henry
caval put a roach on
it put a roach on it
that's the Cockroach from
SpongeBob
yeah that that's the best med credit
scene call that [__] that's still better
than the flash post credit scene I
called that
[__] hey you actually did you called the
cheeseburger you called that you just
all over it I called these uncal things
well you know what I think the costume
were looking fresh this time around
everyone was really popping popping
because of the attire they be wearing
John do the hair thing oh
yeah squid do it for
real you can't do the real version not
anymore where he's like oh wow I'm going
to try to do the oh subtle draw
attention I want to see where it's like
the wind is blowing but not underwater
I'm trying to promote the shirts
guys nothing oh take it
away well I got my America's ass shirt
on of homelander here and he's got his
nip chills John do the hair thing I got
the VNA game that was more natur you're
getting it down there you go guys reject
Nation shop.com thank you so much to
everyone who has been supporting the
channel in the most miraculous way about
picking yourself up some attired or
representing yourself as a citizen of
this great reject nation and we got all
these kinds of shirts right here that
have been amazing Sellers and it makes
me just so happy to see because we're
involved with pretty much all of them uh
creatively wise and and we got more
coming this year so hop on board the
reject Nation train and get yourself a
tea and you look good while doing it
while supporting the channel oh yeah B
listening to so Apple on Spotify we just
watched Aquaman and the lost kingdom
people now now now might I might I kick
this off please might no
no best moment in the entire movie best
reaction ever from Greg let's give it so
funny that was hilarious I all right so
before watching this I really had no
interest in watching it honestly like it
has two of us it had gone down so much
the first trailer was like ah this is
fine it was more the same and then the
second trailer was like I don't give a
[__] about this and then the reviews
came out and it just seemed like no one
was liking this movie and it just
sounded awful and I was like this is
going to be like a tedious boring
experience so my expectations and and I
think for most of us were we somewhere
towards the ground they they were very
much at the bottom of the ocean and
going into it I maybe that had something
to do with it I'm sure it did I'm I'm
100%
confident like if this had crer be like
what the hell is everyone talking about
but uh because they were so bad I
watched this and I kind of like the
first Aquaman movie that was where I
visually appreciated it so much so at
the time but as a narrative I thought it
was kind of a dull film uh the
characters I thought were boring uh I
didn't I was never emotionally hooked
into anything that really happened I
just sort of watched stuff happen and it
was occasionally impressed and kind of
just waited for the next action scene to
happen and this movie moves at such a
fast pace it is a onslaught of noise and
and and just uh Crazy Action but I had
so much fun watching this at times was
it paced in a way where cuz you could
always tell like it just seemed like
every single scene was trimmed every
single you feel that not even where
trimmed there are definitely deleted
scenes in this experience and a lot
tries to get saved by montages and
dialogue overlapping
sequences almost every single scene felt
like it was significantly cut down
however I still think that they managed
to find a way to still be I still feel
like the ultimate end product was
probably very self-aware I still think
that the script at hand that just
because of certain things that are
happening here that there seem to be an
actual Embrace of the silliness of the
cheese the things that people would say
worked about the prior film I think they
just exceptionally tripled down and then
when we were told to cut down the film
they were like well we got to just
double down on that [__] even more we
got to just go through the Mayhem even
more because the action I thought was
consistently really entertaining that
first action scene in Atlantis when uh
when when Atlanta the Nicole kimman
shows up I had that thought going of
there is just so much craziness
happening here but I can I can easily
keep up with what's going on and and I
thought James Juan's Direction you could
actually feel James ju I feel like you
only saw that kind of in doses in the
last Aquaman movie cuz for the most part
I wouldn't feel like James Juan was
behind the camera on that on this one I
felt like I was watching James Juan's
camera work for most of the movie even
if it got like you know tarnished via
editing via Studio interference and
whatever I still felt like I saw his
camera work on display where a lot of
times it looked really cool so I found
myself laughing at the film I found
myself laughing with the film I really
enjoyed the action are there problems so
much
problems but it constantly made up for
only there was only like a 10 to 20
minute stretch where I thought it was
getting a little tedious and a little
dull but for the most part I was do
something with that would just like pull
me back in like I I had that comment at
one point where I was like this movie
should have ended 10 10 to 15 minutes
ago and then they go into this action
scene where or and not orm uh Black
Manta and and Aquaman are are Trident
trid toting it off in this crazy one
take that looks straight out of anime
movement there a camera movement for it
that I was like wow was worth waiting
the extra 10 to 15 minutes for that shot
that was freaking cool you know I had I
had a really fun time with this and I
think the effects were dogged on before
watching and are there some pretty bad
effects at times yeah but are there some
great effects at times yeah you know for
for every bad thing there was something
that would happen that would just kind
of pull me back in and I would get lost
in this
swashbuckling video game anime B movie
sci-fi Mayhem that we were watching so I
had fun with the cacophony honestly I
did and um there's no I have no dog in
this fight to defend it the I never do
and and I especially now like it's over
the DC is over what's the point get that
last minute Shilling in so I had I I I
actually had uh and it's probably more
fun in in you know in in an area like
this where we can like kind of make fun
of the movie and like audibly sure sure
where we don't all have to be silent and
respect yeah and ourselves through
scenes and not like actually let out our
moans and our groans and be like God
this is kind of stupid
because I I thought there was a lot of
inventive wackiness and monstrous Mayhem
happening throughout man so um yeah all
right boys flip a coin let's just do
this at the same time yes like the
reaction ready
go take it away Andrew take it away all
right um well like you Greg and you John
uh I was not the biggest I I know we're
like the three people on the planet I am
the biggest fan of the first yeah we're
we're like the three people on the
planet who didn't care for the first
film um yeah no this one I mean wasn't
the greatest film um but I I like Greg I
had a lot of fun watching it um I think
you said it best during the reaction
like when I one thing I do want to
quickly touch on I know I said Black
Manta um he's a little more menacing in
this I meant the performance I forgot
the actor's name um not the character
itself yes I know he had cordex was
affecting him that whole thing could
have totally been tarnished and I you
know you could have just had the black
Trident and that's how he was able to
power up without the whole cordex thing
I think that would have made it a little
bit better so I'm in total agreement
there I just meant his performance was
much more menacing yes we got way more
screen time than he did in the first
film I just appreciated his performance
a lot more so I just wanted to clear
that up all right no fighting here Greg
um but uh yeah this film was again my
expectations I did not watch any
trailers um for this film because I
don't know why why didn't you invite me
um but
um special trailer watch party don't
know how to do this on my own that's
true I don't have I don't have access to
the trailer I don't have access to the
internet but no I I I again I wasn't the
biggest fan of the first one so I kind
of just avoided the trailers and uh I
did not really have any expectations if
any at all for this film so uh having
said that um I had a lot of fun watching
this one and I think the thing I
appreciated the most besides Patrick
Wilson and Jason M Mo's interactions
Jason mamo's energy it just kind of was
just so infectious and just kind of just
spread on to the audience if you will
and I just loved his performance so much
it was just fun um also too
um who's the elephant in the room was
going to say this but um she was barely
in the film which I I don't think she
needs to be an El the room like she's
really skinny I would call yes yes
exactly pretty fit but um I mean it
wasn't really in the film which is fine
I didn't either way didn't really bother
me um
but I can't really say anything I would
say like from a narrative point of view
like why you making it weird Andrew why
am I making whatever's presence is like
most every other supporting character's
presence doesn't feel particularly
pointed I would say from a Nar I mean if
we're going to get into narratives
though in terms of characters and arcs
and all that I mean I I really didn't
think Aquaman had much to do in the film
yeah he had to free his brother and you
know there was the emotional Arc there
but terms of a character Arc like you
know accepting being the king and and
that like cuz he kind of said you know
in one of his interactions with his
brother that you know I never wanted to
be king I don't like it and then by the
end of the film like okay what has
changed other than uh your brother said
like you have to make the hard decisions
and you do that so well I'm like okay
that's it well in the last one he felt
like he wasn't worthy of being King and
this one he learns to kind of be like
all right I I'm okay with being King oh
Stell never never mind I take back
everything I that's why they throw a lot
of [__] at your face to distract you
okay but having said that the action
sequences were a lot of fun I'll be at a
few CGI things but like Greg said there
were a lot of CGI that I really did
appreciate whereas in the first film
again there were some great CGI shots
but there were a lot to I was just like
just jarring for me and just uh just in
your- face not enjoyable in my sense
just taking me out of the film um but
this film I I app appreciate it a lot
more um overall though again it's it was
a fun time is the best word I would use
to describe this film um it's nothing
super deep or anything but I don't think
it was trying to be I appreciated how
self-aware it was I mean even called him
Loki when I mean I mentioned you know me
my I'm a reference machine and I even
said it's like Thor the Dark World so
like Hey we're trying to do Thor the
Dark World let's just I'm just going to
call you Loki here you know my I mean so
I I I actually appreciated it was aware
that how ridiculous it was being and it
was self-aware so I mean he should of
just does the I am Iron Man thing at the
end and I feel like I know they
drop yeah totally but uh yeah no I mean
J Mo and and I know this film got a
lower rating score of 5.9 I believe and
the first film got like a 6.8 or
whatever I don't care I Who on IMDb uh I
don't care but I like this film more
than the first one personally but I
thought it was more fun at least than
the first one you know in terms of
narratives I think they're both shite
but um but I think this one was more if
I ever had to rewatch this one or the
second or the first one excuse me I
would definitely rewatch this one yeah
uh I I like if anything at least for the
no I would rewat it for that no no
no um yeah I I just think the
seriousness in the first one I I could
never take anything seriously and I was
just either laughing at it or but I feel
like I would laugh at it without it
without it
like any any awareness that like this is
they really want to be taken seriously
right now and so here they were like
screw all
seriousness we're not even going to
really try and really quick to your
point just really quick and I'll let JN
go to your point there was a scene in
the very first film where black manta's
uh father was uh about to die and like
he's doing the slow dramatic run as he
I'm like I don't care about either of
these characters and why like No And
like with rer gregson's William uh
Williams's music I'm like this this is
so ridiculous how serious it's trying to
be right now and so to your point I
completely agree with you John I felt
like melodramatic where this had no
drama it was
just brush over the serious stuff but
there's a positive message and [__] in
it it's nice yeah all right John do all
the criticisms sure the lack of
Supporting Cast black Mansa being a weak
character yet again a waste of big
villain at the end predictability come
on there's a lot of bad things well this
this is a fun and interesting experience
in this movie because this movie
represents uh so many of the pitfalls
that so many other DC EU movies have had
and I feel like yeah on the heels of the
first Aquaman I'm like so much about
this movie is like really similar to
that movie uh and even though that movie
has an extra half hours worth of
breathing room this movie having half
hours less Breathing Room comes AC like
the first Aquaman is like the okayest of
this entire wave to me it's like flat in
the middle there's not much origal about
it it's a little too serious but it's
got a big imagination in this movie I
think there are a lot of bugs that come
out of the choice to make it fast and
Breezy but a lot of those bugs become
features and I think that's what it's
like yeah hearing the response to this
movie has been fascinating because to me
especially now having seen it it feels
like a lot of people's processing of
this was very much ingrained in where it
falls in the franchise how much of a
point is there to having this experience
at all if we removed all that I'm
sitting here looking at this and
thinking to myself this is a perfectly
fun swashbuckling silly movie that that
manages to go after some of that Lord of
the Ring scale but instead of doing it
in all the weight of the crown and the
drama we're going to do it in the scope
of all the crazy ass places we got to go
and uh and yeah I mean you know are is
your whole Supporting Cast like winnowed
down to the point where you forget half
them are there until they show back up
again like Amber herd not being here it
it would be one thing if she was the
only character that was happening to but
like pretty much every character I would
forget about except for Arthur and orm
and kind of manta Shin is really like
the third guy on that totem pole I was
always having in mind really and then
Manta way down here and then everybody
else way down here so yeah like it's
weird there are plenty of criticisms to
Levy and none of that stuff is really
what comes to the Forefront of my mind
like it's yeah you get the glob trotting
swashbuckling gallivanting you get some
fun imagination you get your tributes
that are obvious without feeling like
they're too impressed with themselves
for doing those tributes in the first
place and uh yeah you know I I feel like
for the conclusion of this it's a little
funky it's a little weird but uh I don't
know I thought the the just the like you
said I've seen a lot of things
especially in this wave of Cinema that
are noticeably retooled and reworked and
I've seen versions of that that go over
a lot more poorly than this does so I am
kind of f fated at the response to this
being as overtly sort of like we knew
this was going to suck and it did
whereas I sit here and I kind of agree
with you I'm like I would sooner
probably throw this on as opposed to the
first movie because at least this movie
you we can get all the angsty [__] out
of the way and now we're just having fun
you know and and like yeah gripes about
Manta you know I feel bad for Yahya
because even though I guess he had more
screen time I felt like he had less
screen time and they do that thing that
has plagued a lot of these DC movies
black adom comes most freshly to mind
because it was most recent but like yeah
we have this demon guy who looks cool
and comes from a cool place and that guy
is basically just going to take over
this other guy who we actually have like
an emotional connection to and then he's
going to become the villain and like
it's cool but also like we just go to
Dun Harrow at the end and do the dead
army from Lord of the Rings for a hot
minute and then we're done but like yeah
like that's a TR and like that goes even
back to you you can find that in Wonder
Woman and so many other of the DC movies
and that's what I think is funny here is
that they really did just like pull one
of their tricks out and go yeah that's
going to be the villain instead of going
with in relation to this and many other
superhero movies lately I've heard
people say we don't always need the
world rending Stakes sometimes personal
Stakes are better and this is an
instance where I'm like damn it man if
they just made Black Manta have all they
had to do is have him maintain his
agency he can go team up with cordex or
whatever he wants but like have him
maintain the agency so I care when the
character shows up cuz it really made
everything with him super super silly
agreed my big what my biggest comp my
biggest complaint actually over
everything is that I think they bought
black man had some cool fight moments
and there were some cool visuals around
like I like the enhancement of the
glowing of the red eyes like through the
smoke and the mist and you just see it
like blending in with it I thought was
really cool uh but in terms of a
character you know there is this like
big scene where he you know he's going
to he's threatening uh Dr Shin with the
the blade and he's like you want to know
my ultimate plan and he just reiterates
him like yeah there's nothing new here
that I thought we wait he wasn't in on
this from like the very beginning this
seems like the exact same plan and as a
character I don't I did I thought they
completely wasted him yet again
completely he's just more more brooding
like he was already one note in the
first movie like with this like a layer
of oh I lost my father so I guess it's
not entirely I felt like Yaya was at
least bringing trying to bring like a
death to the first movie and then this
one I think he saw how shitty this was
and decided whatever I'm just going to
go full force I'm just aggressive and it
was way more one note uh this movie
didn't give a [__] about that character
at all it's very obvious like Atlanta I
don't uh Nicole kimman was like her
presence that's the thing is the it's
not just that they had less screen time
it's that their presence wasn't even
felt you would that's why you would
forget about them you know Atlanta she
would be there yeah yeah she's in the
movie um and then merera especially that
was the one where I do think it seems
very apparent that they certainly cut
some [__] out it seemed like she should
have been more involved bare minimum
requisite amount they gave her CU
because at first she's in it and I'm
you're like why isn't she ever with him
on land with the baby like you never see
them as a family together and there's so
much emphasis on the baby I might care
more about this baby literally Poss the
baby's M yeah and then uh when she shows
up when she gets harmed like okay well
she's not going to die maybe should be
more important then she just kind of
just shows up for a couple of few badass
moments but she doesn't feel like a
character and I feel like Dolph London
weirdly felt way more like a character
than the other two but that's like a
barely a compliment because he was just
that voice The Voice he kind to do some
weird like dude voice the whole muscle
King it's a weird voice yeah but I liked
Patrick Wilson uh I thought he was
having fun it was nice to see them like
lining up in a way that didn't feel like
they were sabotaging the characters that
came prior I don't feel like orm was
necessarily a bad guy in the first movie
that I I kind of understood where he was
coming from like yeah if I was in this
guy's position I told it' be like the
surfice people are bad why not why
wouldn't you think that and to see them
kind of deconstruct that pull that layer
back I thought was fun him and Jason Mo
had good chemistry great music in this
movie throughout and and again I feel
like there's an actual like the first
movie certainly breathes better the
first movie certainly feels like for all
for all purposes it's a movie a movie it
actually feels like a movie and feels
like some weird project but Bri had so
much more fun watching this one than I
did the other one they both have these
qualities that feel so requisite in how
they're telling their St stories and I
think the choice of pacing this one this
way just works better if you're going to
do that yeah cuz I I at least like um I
I still feel like wow there's some cool
James Wan isms in this one and versus
the last one where people like oh you
know that trench scene when they see the
trench people that's like a James one
moment right and Le juanell has a cameo
so so it's super James one but
everything else just felt like it could
have been directed by somebody else and
and this was the first time
you know there maybe that had something
more to do with more scenes being not in
Ocean uh but a little more like
different locations more land stuff
where but even under underwater I think
he he got a better grip on a lot of the
visuals for like I like the more sci-fi
populated cities I really felt more like
oh instead of just populating with a
bunch of CGI creatures I actually got a
sense I bet a lot of it was cut down
really get that but but you got a sense
like that gangster World it feels like
Star Wars like everything feels like
it's like you know ripping off something
else for sure they got traffic and they
got a bar you know they got all sorts of
stuff they had job of the Hut they had
news yeah just King stuff and Dolph lren
did say that a lot of the film was cut
down so I mean as always you know we got
to release the WAN cut um but I'd say
the most unbelievable thing that we saw
especially from black mana's character
especially at the beginning that took us
all immediately out was that the the
helmet we saw was cut straight down but
the the scar was in a diagonal L it's
like I don't understand that yeah it was
a weird I mean it probably would look
stupid honestly
straight supervision choice just had the
helmet what looks cool on one thing
looks different on another thing so we
got to have them both be cool like it's
a movie about a man who can swim just I
mean he barely does King stuff they have
so much so that they have to lay out
what he did at the very end so that way
we know what he did as a king like when
orms were citing all that I was going I
didn't really pick up on any of that all
the stuff about you know hey you're
willing to do the hard things and when
when doing the wrong thing is easy and
you know even helping out going to your
worst enemy I'm like yeah there's like
no real emotion to any of that [__]
throughout this journey but I'm glad you
laid that out doing what he has to do
I'm glad you told me what was going on
yeah but in a way that's better that's
that's good it's we should be able to
look back and be like oh he is right
isn't he yeah but for the tone of this
film I mean I don't know
I don't care cuz yeah it was fun it's
it's fun there's somebody there like an
actual style to it though at the same
time there's style there's purpose and
there's like truly rewarding action
visual scenes you know it feels like
people showed up it feels like they
maintained a spirit of fun along the way
and it feels like they didn't give up
when the movie got gutted like it seems
like they really worked to smooth it out
as best they could like there are
sequences in visuals that I would gladly
like look up a clip for you know I don't
know if I'd ever watch this
movie start to look up certain scenes
key moments the one where those crabby
things are going it's very inventive
there was that one where the crabby
things are going like into the wall and
like that was pretty cool I mean yeah
quite a few of those no it's got a lot
of imagination and a lot of like fun
comic book stuff like this felt more
like paging through some kind of
swashbuckling comic book yeah it's more
madap Skull Island it's everything it's
a whole bunch of things it's a whole
bunch of movies just smashed into one
yeah in a in a way where once in a while
it's you know at time at times though I
did I would find myself craving all
right slow it down a little bit so
because you got to have a bit of a
balance that way the madness can be more
rewarding and enjoyable you you just
need that balance to so because if it's
just at one pace which it is I guess
that's if I had one actual gripe it
would be that
like I think they could have spent any
amount of time and I know people will
winge if Amber herd's in this movie
anymore but I think it would have been a
more conscientious choice to favor the
movie and maybe show them as a family
just a little bit that baby becomes more
than just a literal McGuffin when she's
just in like her same outfit the entire
movie just show she doesn't get more
than a couple lines in any of her scenes
which I watched something like this and
I'm like it's distracting I know people
lost their minds when that court case
was going on but you know what make the
movie smooth and just feature her a
little bit more in appropriate places
yeah I mean if you're going to feature
her you might as well commit yeah you
know like she's going to she's in it
it's not like she shows up in the
beginning and leaves forever like you
know she's you're intermittently placing
her throughout you might as well commit
to Arthur's freaking baby and we barely
even spend time like once we leave the
baby after the prologue I had to like
the movie once it cut back I was
reminded like oh [__] he's got a kid
that's right oh yeah and I mean you do
see mirror there in the beginning for
like a tiny bit but like her they're
leaving yeah I was like wait a minute
where do she's is she like like
sometimes staying here and then she ever
come see the kid Yeah because sometimes
she's not like what is the living
situation Arthur with it seems like
Arthur constantly buzzes off and just
stays on land and like screw the kingdom
this is where I sleep this is my home
you know but he clocks out at 6 is like
not there ever this is strange I'm like
guys I get it I know you hate this
person for various reasons we won't talk
about that it's a good idea for a
spin-off though it would be nice yeah if
if this baby's mother was around if
we're going to commit to the idea that
she and Arthur are still together all
right well would you like more the flash
of this Andrew wow what a question Jesus
oh my goodness why do you have to put me
on
um oh God H this was definitely more fun
I would probably choose this but oh
Michael Keaton's my favorite Batman the
highs and Flash are higher but this is a
much more consistent experience I would
probably choose to watch this but I I
but I I'm like watching Michael Keaton
back as Batman but I I would probably
choose this this is a movie I I wanted
to stay looking at no matter what
whereas there are many times during
flash where I would rather not look at
what is on screen yeah the as much as I
think the answer should be probably
flash I think I would probably watch
this sooner the two bar Allens just
really annoyed me but I would probably
say the uh I'd probably choose this I
feel like the flash is probably a more
cohesive movie much stronger like a more
a better movie probably i' rather watch
this I'm talking movie versus experience
sure it's probably a better conceived
and assembled film maybe perhaps also
too being such a fan of flasho paradox
in general I'd rather watch this yeah I
just feel like that was such a misguided
decision in general but I miss Jason I
didn't think I would until he was here
he seemed even more even though like a
lot of the takes weren't consistent you
could tell that there were REO he had a
tear shedding dud one scene I mean he
committed you got yeah I'm going to miss
him as Aquaman I was like oh you know
what I am going to miss him still hey
but the good news my man yeah he's still
going to remain in the D whatever
they're calling it um so that's good
news I guess oh and not I guess I'm
happy he's still sticking around Lobo or
what whoever he's going to be so that's
the question because they don't have any
Aquaman stuff slated right now so are
they going to do this thing where they
do like a phase one and then go okay
this is going all right oh we're
bringing him back as Arthur Curry or are
they going to go Lobo because I feel
like they could do
either one man this is an ending with
huge implications that apparently is not
going to matter at all yeah
open nowhere they gave vibranium to the
world it's a huge ending that's like
it's not none of it matters now yeah go
big or go home or go big and go home
even though nothing ended up happening
from here are you guys sad we didn't get
a Ben Affleck scene or a Michael Keaton
scene I I just would have loved to have
seen a especially because they actually
got him to come back we saw it and
originally they were supposed to have
Michael Keaton do a scene as well but
yeah and I think you are right like that
that whole meeting at the end I'm like
it does seem weird for the Justice
League not to be like here welcome one
of our team standing in the back you
know here for support yeah like we all
up we talked about this first remember
that Steen wolf thing yeah I was there
to help
out I was a part of that so you guys
know me from that and now I'm in the
spotlight here and I want to talk to you
about ecology saving the planet yeah I
mean knowing that this is it I
understand why but yes agreed they they
do distracting Justice League cameos in
every other movie they should have done
would it even been cool if they did the
Shazam thing just showing them from the
back with their show them but just their
butts all we needed
was Wonder Woman theme
them on top of and just yeah they're all
showing up all righty guys what did you
think about Aquaman in the lost kingdom
did you love it did you hate it do you
agree with all the critics do you think
it's better than the first one do you
what come on what's your honest take on
it are you going to miss Amber herd as
Queen Mara yes leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that Bell leave a
like and uh we will catch you all
flippity Flip
Flip
oh